SPEAKER 1: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a plethora of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch the session Connected
Retail and Devices,
then stay tuned,
because here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As technology improves
in the public sector,
it's straightforward to
expect that it'll influence
the commercial sector as well.
In fact, it's already
predicted that by 2020,
72% of US workforce will
work from a mobile location.
SPEAKER 2: Which
brings up big questions
about how we create
the right technology
and ecosystems to
support connected work
spaces and connected
storefronts in the future.
Now there's two
sides to this coin.
First is how you
instrument, analyze,
and improve the
connectivity and data
flow of your internal workers.
SPEAKER 1: On the other side,
the storefront of the future
has to find a way to
combine the benefits
of the physical retail
space and the benefits
of the connected digital
space without making
it more difficult for
customers or employees.
For example, with a
mobile-enabled staff,
updates and information
can be pushed out
to employees on the show floor.
Meanwhile, they can update
the main stocking databases
in real time.
Or if signage is
more of your style,
replacing physical
signs with digital ones
has seen a lowering in cost
and allowing more variability
and control over time.
SPEAKER 2: On the
cutting edge of things
is virtual reality and
augmented reality, which
could help customers get
a better sense of what
the products would look
like in their own homes
and your store managers get
a more immersive experience
in what installations would look
like inside your retail spaces.
And of course, let's not
forget those metrics.
A newly connected
retail means the ability
to detect when users are
near product, triggering
local changes and
giving feedback to you
on what product
is being engaged.
SPEAKER 1: Now in this
talk a very special partner
takes the stage to
show how they've
utilized all these
technologies to create
a strong, interactive, and
next-generation display system
for their retail operations.
But you should really go
watch the full video of that.
We're not going to be able to do
that presentation justice here.
So if you want to see more
recaps on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Next
World Tour coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]